the Western world is facing a
significant threat it is in danger
because those who are supposed to defend
the values of the western world are
co-opted by a world viw that inevitably
leads to socialism and consequently to
poverty and economic deprivation
unfortunately in recent decades
motivated by some well-intentioned
desires to help others and others by the
desire to belong to a privileged cast
the main leaders of the western world
have abandoned the model of freedom for
different versions of what we call
collectivism we are here to tell you
that collectivist experiments are never
the solution to the problems that
afflict the citizens of the world he's
talking about the values of the West and
the values of the west of course are
based in the individual that it is you
first our governments are supposed to
protect our rights not give us rights
and that is completely counter to the
wef message it's completely counter to
what we are now seeing as socialism and
communism or Marxism it doesn't even
matter what you want to call it as it
creeps through all of these Western
governments